RONALD SMITH: Right in the
middle of a section on
oceanography.
We started about a week ago.
And we started by talking
about ocean basins.
We talked about the salt in
the sea, where that comes
from, how it's distributed.
And now we're getting
into ocean currents.
And I began this subject last
time, but I wanted--
before I get into the subject
again, I wanted to tell you
what we're trying to do,
in terms of the way we
organize--the way oceanographers
organize their
thinking about ocean currents.
For the most part, we try to
break them down into two broad
categories thermohaline
and wind driven.
And you could define them, I
guess, in the simplest way.
Thermohaline would be all
currents that are driven by
the density differences
in the ocean.
Thermohaline is the name for
that, because temperature and
salt determine the density.
And then gravity acts on those
density differences to produce
so-called thermohaline
circulations.
And we can't really do this
experiment, but at least in
the back of our minds, we can
imagine that if we turned off
all the forcing at the ocean
surface that related to
temperature and salt for
example, we shut off all the
heat fluxes in and out of the
ocean, and we shut off all the
fresh water fluxes in and out of
the ocean, the thermohaline
circulation should cease.
So at least that would
be their definition.
If we turned off that kind
of forcing, then those
circulations would stop.
Wind driven is driven by the
wind stresses at the surface
of the ocean.
And there again, a way to define
that, or perhaps an
imaginary one would be, if you
could magically turn off all
the winds, then perhaps not at
that instant, but over some
days or weeks, all the wind
driven currents in the oceans
would cease.
Now, the thing to remember,
though, about both of these
types of currents, they're
not driven
locally by those forces.
In other words, you could have
wind blowing from west to
east, and have, at that same
location, wind driven currents
in the opposite direction.
For example, these large gyres
are driven by the mean wind
stresses, westerlies in
mid-latitudes, easterlies in
low latitudes.
And there well may be, in fact,
there are many places in
the ocean where the local wind
driven currents are opposite
to the local winds.
So don't get confused by that.
They're still wind
driven currents.
If you turned off all the wind
stresses, those currents would
cease over time.
Now, the problem with this nice,
clean categorization is
that there are some ocean
currents that seem to be
driven by a mix of
the two things.
For example, the Gulf Stream,
which I'll be talking about
today, is generally considered
by oceanographers to be a wind
driven current.
On the other hand, it carries
warm water northward, some of
which cools and sinks, and
returns underneath in the deep
ocean, towards the south
as a colder current.
So at that point, it seems
to be more of a
thermohaline current.
So some fraction of the Gulf
Stream, quote, wind driven,
returns southward as a
thermohaline current.
So there is an example where
we can't quite make that
distinction as cleanly
as we might like.
We just have to live
with that, though.
And as our models of ocean
currents become more
sophisticated, we can try to
apply those definitions more
and more securely to
understanding these
differences.
Any questions on that?
So I'll just back up for a
moment or two here, and remind
you what we talked about with
respect to thermohaline
circulations.
They're driven by density.
Typically, they tend to be slow
currents, probably no
more than maybe a couple of
centimeters per second.
Like about this.
Maybe even slower
in the ocean.
So they're quite slow.
They do, however, extend, in
some cases, right down to the
bottom of the ocean.
As opposed to wind driven
currents, which are usually in
the upper kilometer, so the
upper fifth or so, of the
ocean column.
They're responsible for the
water mass distributions.
We talked about the ones
in the Atlantic Ocean.
That conveyor belt circulation
between the Pacific and the
Atlantic Ocean.
And these estuaries, and inverse
estuary circulations
are all thermohaline
circulations.
We talked about that.
Stop me if you have any
questions on these sections.
We went over them before.
That was a north-south section
for temperature in the
Atlantic, for salinity
in the Atlantic.
Oh, I didn't mention
one thing that
probably should be discussed.
There was this blob of salty
water you'd expect the water
in the tropics and subtropics
to be salty, because there's
an excess of evaporation at
the surface of the ocean.
But what explains this blob of
salty water is actually that
outflow from the Mediterranean
Sea.
That salty outflow from the
Mediterranean Sea then moves
westward across the Atlantic
Ocean, and catches us in this
north-south section.
So this is if that's north and
that's south, then that's west
and that's east. This is the
Mediterranean water coming
into this section from the east
as an outflow from the
Mediterranean.
So it flows over the sill
there in the Straits of
Gibraltar, flows down till it
finds it's appropriate density
level, where the water above
it is less dense, the water
below it is more dense.
And then it floats horizontally
as a tongue of
salty water, finally reaching
that section.
It's part of the reason why the
North Atlantic deep water
is generally salty, because the
Mediterranean water gets
entrained into that North
Atlantic deep water.
We talked about the oxygen.
And this was the summary of the
in a north-south section
of the Atlantic Ocean
thermohaline circulations.
Any questions on this?
So this is the Antarctic
intermediate water, the North
Atlantic deep water, and the
Antarctic bottom water.
We talked about this.
OK.
Now, I got into wind driven
currents a bit.
I want to review that as well.
The chain of events, as we
understand it today, is that
the wind stress produces a
shallow transport of water in
the layer that feels that
wind stress directly.
That's a pretty shallow layer,
probably only 100 meters deep.
And in that layer, the water
gets pushed off to the right
of the wind stress, in the
Northern Hemisphere.
That Ekman layer transport
piles up water.
For example, in the middle of
the North Atlantic gyre,
there's this piling up
of Ekman layer drift.
And that, in turn, that slight
non-uniformity in the height
of the ocean surface, generates
pressure gradients
beneath horizontal pressure
gradients that then generate
geostrophic ocean currents.
I mentioned that we can now
measure this, and I'll show
you that plot again
in just a moment.
But it dawned on me that I
forgot to mention that there
were clues to this, even
in the early days.
For example, the center of the
North Atlantic gyre is
referred to as the
Sargasso Sea.
Does anyone know where
that term,
Sargasso Sea, comes from?
It's an old term.
It goes back several
hundred years.
If you take a ship across the
Atlantic, through the middle
of this gyre, when you get into
that region of the ocean,
you begin to see floating
pockets of plant material.
It's mostly sargassum weed.
It's floating there.
And the reason why it's
collected there is because of
the Ekman currents
pushing it there.
So we had some clue that that
was a region of convergence,
even before we could measure
that sea surface height
anomaly from satellites.
If you dumped in and now that
there's more pollution in the
ocean, people have dumped loads
of trash into the ocean
that floats, some of that
is found in the
Sargasso Sea as well.
It's just an area where water
tends to collect, and then, of
course, sink eventually.
But in the collecting, all the
things that float remain kind
of gathered there in the
middle of the ocean.
We've also found these
gatherings in the middle of
the other ocean gyres.
So there's evidence that ocean
water does collect there, and
the things that float are
still found there.
So the fact that it's called the
Sargasso Sea gives another
clue to this sequence
of events.
So there's the winds, and
there's the ocean topography,
as measured from space.
With units in centimeters,
typically it's only a
topography of about like this.
You would never notice
it if you were
sailing through there.
But the water is slightly higher
there than the geoid of
the earth, there's a surface
you can imagine, nearly a
sphere, which we consider
to be the level surface.
And this rises slightly above
that level surface.
And then, in turn, gives rise
to the pressure gradients
underneath that.
And these are the wind
driven currents.
I don't want you to memorize all
these names, except some
of them probably should be
known, and some of them are
quite obvious, that it's
hard, once you've seen
them, not to know them.
For example, the Brazil Current
runs down the coast of
Brazil, the Peru Current runs
up the coast of Peru, the
California Current, the Alaska
Current, the West Australian
Current, the East Australian
current.
Pretty hard to forget those
once you've seen them.
The Gulf Stream is part of
the North Atlantic gyre.
The word gyre is spelled
G-Y-R-E, and it refers to
these circular current systems.
Forced to be circular
because the continents prevent
them from going all the way
around the earth.
Only in the southern ocean,
where you get the Antarctic
Circumpolar Current, do you get
a current going all the
way around the ocean.
Otherwise, the continents break
up these wind driven
currents into gyres.
The North Atlantic Gyre consists
of the Gulf Stream,
the North Atlantic Drift, the
Canary Current, and the North
Equatorial Current.
Some of the Gulf Stream,
however, breaks off and
becomes the North Atlantic
Drift, which eventually goes
into the Arctic Ocean.
You can have reverse currents
in the very high latitudes,
like the Alaska Current.
Notice that goes opposite to the
main North Pacific Gyre.
And the Labrador Current, in
a sense, goes a little bit
opposite to the North Atlantic
Gyre, as well.
The equivalent to the Gulf
Stream in the Pacific Ocean is
the Kuroshio Current.
And there's a lot of studies
kind of comparing those two
currents, because they play the
equivalent role in the two
large Northern Hemisphere
basins.
They're both warm currents.
And you can find equivalent
things in the Southern
Hemisphere as well.
The three warm currents would
be the Brazil Current, the
Agulhas Current, and the East
Australian Current.
Each returning equatorially
warmed water down into the
high latitude colder areas.
Near the equator, things can
get pretty complicated.
You can have an equatorial
counter current.
And notice that this would be
the region of the trade winds.
Blowing from east to west. And
yet, there's the counter
current, a wind driven current,
I propose to you.
And yet it's running opposite
to the local wind direction.
So that's one of those confusing
points where the
winds don't always seem
to be pushing the
currents around locally.
But then again, that has to do
with this indirect effect.
It's not just the wind blowing
on the water to make it move.
You've got that chain of events,
the Ekman layer, the
piling up of the water, and then
the geostrophic currents.
It's not a direct, air pushes
water, water moves scenario.
It's a little more complicated
than that.
Another interesting fact, which
is why we have to have
this slightly more complex
theory, is that these ocean
currents, for the most part,
do extend about a kilometer
down into the ocean.
They don't extend
to the bottom.
But they extend about a
kilometer down, and that's far
deeper than the wind stress
is felt directly.
So in order to explain that,
we have to have this more
complicated theory.
Then it's the pressure gradients
which extend down to
about a kilometer below the
surface that are generating
these so-called wind
driven currents.
When I say they're
geostrophically driven, or
geostrophically balanced, I
mean they have a balance
between pressure gradient force
and Coriolis force.
Where does wind appear
then in that?
If it's Coriolis force and
pressure gradient force, does
that mean wind is not active?
No.
Wind was important
in setting up the
pressure gradient force.
So wind is still in there, even
though it doesn't appear
directly in that
force balance.
Any questions on this current
map of the world?
OK.
Now, we try to estimate how much
water is moving in each
of these currents.
Now, in some cases,
it's easy to do.
For example, where the Antarctic
Circumpolar Current
passes through the Drake
Passage, between the Antarctic
peninsula and the southern tip
of South America, that's a
well-defined channel,
if you like.
And so, we can measure with
ships and so on, and current
meters, we can measure
how much water
flows between there.
And that would be a local
measurement of the Antarctic
Circumpolar Current.
In other places, for example,
the Gulf Stream, where do you
put the outer edge?
OK, it does weaken as
you go out, as I'll
show you in a minute.
But it's still a little bit
ambiguous about where you mark
the outer edge of
the Gulf Stream.
Nonetheless, we have come up
with these estimates for this
isn't inclusive, but it's a few
examples of estimates of
how much discharge are in some
of the major ocean currents
around the world.
And we're using the unit of
Sverdrup here, which is named
after a famous oceanographer.
It's not really an
SI unit, but it's
closely related to one.
It's simply one million cubic
meters per second.
So it's a volumetric discharge
rate, just like we've been
using in rivers.
It's a million cubic
meters per second.
And one way to remember this,
that if you add up all the
discharge of rivers in the
world, all the freshwater
rivers dumping water into
the ocean, the number is
approximately one Sverdrup.
It just turns out, by accident,
to be that way.
So it's easy to remember.
Summing up the Amazon, the
Mississippi, all the major
rivers, you get a number
something like this.
It's a good comparison point
for then looking at the
discharge in the
ocean currents.
The Florida Current, which is
where the Gulf Stream is
passing up along the coast
of Florida, it's only 30
Sverdrups there.
But a few hundred miles north
of there, where it's just
leaving Cape Hatteras and
heading eastward, If you do a
north-south section
through it, it's
grown to 150 Sverdrups.
One of the strongest currents
in the world.
The Labrador Current, that
cold current coming down
through the Gulf of Maine and
reaching, in some cases, even
Massachusetts, has about
eight Sverdrups.
That Antarctic Circumpolar
Current that I mentioned, at
least where it passes
through the Drake
Passage, is 110 Sverdrups.
And the Kuroshio Current
is 50 Sverdrups.
Somewhere between these two
estimates for the Gulf Stream.
So these are just round numbers,
but they'll give you
some sense for how much water
is moving around in these
ocean currents.
So let's focus on the Atlantic
Ocean for a few minutes.
It's complicated.
The Antarctic Circumpolar
Current flows along at the
southern edge of it.
Some cold water gets peeled off
and put northwards into
the Benguela Current.
And we've talked about the role
that this place plays in
keeping the south equatorial
Atlantic rather cool.
Very few hurricanes
form in here.
And the ITCZ never really shifts
south of the equator in
this ocean.
And that's because of the cold
water being brought up by the
Benguela Current.
There is a South Pacific--sorry
a South
Atlantic Gyre.
And it consists of the South
Equatorial Current, the Brazil
Current, the South Atlantic
Current, and then the return
in the Benguela Current.
The equatorial region.
The equator is here.
It's a little complicated.
There are some counter-currents.
So let's shift up into the
Northern Hemisphere, where
I'll spend most of
my time here.
And that is, you've got another
gyre, a subtropical
gyre, consisting of
the Gulf Stream.
Some would call this the Gulf
Stream extension, or the North
Atlantic Current.
It returns in the Canary Current
and then the North
Equatorial Current there.
Some of this enters into
the Caribbean Sea.
Then between Mexico and
Cuba, it flows up
into the Gulf of Mexico.
Then comes out right along
the coast of Florida.
And that's the number I quoted
you for the Florida Current.
But then additional water joins
it, and by the time it
gets out here, it has more total
transport than it had as
it moved up along the
coast of Florida.
So that's oh, then you've got
the Labrador Current up here.
Water coming down out of the
Arctic Ocean moves along the
east coast of Greenland, back
up along the west coast and
Baffin Bay, and then becomes
the Labrador Current, then
comes down here.
And that's a cold current.
So the Gulf Stream was
discovered, well it was known,
in a way, from the earliest
sailing expeditions across the
Atlantic Ocean.
But actually, it was Ben
Franklin who did the first
scientific study of it.
By looking at ship's logs.
He, himself, took that trip a
couple of times when he was
posted as being ambassador
to the French court.
And he would take observations
as he traveled across.
And this is his map from
approximately 1769.
We'll compare that with what
we know today about it.
But he's got the basic
idea right.
It comes up along the coast of
Florida to the Cape Hatteras,
and then seems to leave the
coast and move out towards the
east. And doesn't come that
close to us here in
Connecticut, we're
right there.
He doesn't show anything
splitting off to go up north,
the way the previous
diagram did.
Here's a satellite image.
One really neat way to look
at this is just to take an
infrared, a thermal infrared
image of the ocean.
Play some tricks to get rid of
the clouds, and then interpret
the intensity of that radiation
as the temperature
of the emitting object.
Remember the Stefan-Boltzmann
law the warmer an object is,
the more it radiates.
So that's what's done here.
A color code has been applied.
The red is areas that are
emitting strongly in the
thermal infrared.
The blue are areas that are
emitting less strongly.
And then that's directly related
to the temperature of
the sea surface.
So this is sea surface
temperature.
Warm water in the tropics.
And then this little
stream of very warm
water coming up here.
It's getting mixed in a little
bit, but it continues as a
warm water current, until
it leaves Cape Hatteras.
We see it continuing, but as
soon as it leaves, it begins
to meander.
And you form eddies
on both sides.
Cold eddies poking through from
west to east. Warm eddies
from east to west. And
it begins to mix in.
However, you can still
see remnants of it
further across the ocean.
And it still has a pretty good
speed there, but it's losing
some of its thermal
characteristic as it mixes in
with the environment.
So that's a good view.
But remember, this is going
to be changing with time.
So if you were to take another
image a week or so later if
you took it just a day
or so later, it would
look a lot like this.
But if you took--if you waited
a week and took another image
of it, those eddies would have
moved around quite a bit, and
new ones would have formed.
And it would look
quite different.
Here's a zoom in on
another date.
Again, the trick is the same.
We're looking at sea surface
temperature derived from
emitted long wave radiation.
And here's Delaware Bay, Long
Island Sound, and there's just
a little bit of the tip
of Cape Hatteras.
So you see the warm water
coming up here.
This may be a little bit of the
Labrador Current coming
down in here.
And then you've got the
mid-ocean, the Sargasso Sea
out here in the middle.
A quote from one of the first
books to lay down a
description of this, was
a book by Matthew
Fontaine Maury in 1855.
Where he was working for the
Navy and he put togehter--
gathered together information
from ships' logs.
From all the US Navy ships.
And wrote this rather remarkable
book called The
Physical Geography of the Sea.
And here's a quote
from that book.
"No feature of the Gulf Stream
excites remarks among seamen
more frequently than the
sharpness of its edges,
particularly along its inner
borders." He's referring to
this edge here.
When you sail across that, you
really notice that boundary.
In part, because of
what he says.
The color of the water changes
from the bright indigo of the
tropical to the dirty green
of the litoral.
So you're getting this water is
basically a clear tropical
light blue, but the
water back here is
rather dirty and green.
And you see that boundary
very, very sharply as
you sail across it.
There are other things, though,
that a sailor would
notice as well.
There tends to be cumulus clouds
often over the warm
Gulf Stream, but not over
the cold water.
That's to be expected, because
the warm water would
destabilize the atmospheric
boundary layer, and cause
thermal convection.
So when you're approaching that,
you can often see it at
quite some distance, because
you see cumulus clouds are
building up over the Gulf
Stream Questions?
Now, what about this Gulf of
Mexico thing that's rather
interesting.
It's called the Loop Current.
Remember, so the--as part of
the North Atlantic Gyre,
you've got water pushing into
the Caribbean Sea, then coming
up into the Gulf of Mexico in
a well-defined current.
But that current
is not steady.
It changes from week to week,
and it goes through a cycle.
A rather interesting cycle.
For a few weeks, it'll seem to
turn directly eastward and end
up in the Florida Current.
Then that loop seems
to elongate.
Then that will break off, it
will form a clockwise eddy,
which will then drift off.
And the shortcut is then
reestablished.
It's more like this.
That eddy will eventually drift
into the western part of
the Gulf of Mexico, and the
cycle will then continue.
So it's an unsteady current
going through this cyclic
behavior of taking a shortcut,
extending in a long path, and
then breaking off
into a new eddy.
And you can see that in
satellite images.
And here's a sequence
of satellite images.
And the dates are given here.
They're from 1998.
But there's the loop.
And then as it drifts westward,
it weakens.
The new direct link is
established there to get water
into the Florida current.
So depending when you're down
there, you're going to find
either a lot of warm water here
or not, depending where
you are in the phase of this
cyclic alteration.
OK.
Well, I'm not going to go into
the Pacific Ocean currents
nearly as deeply.
If you want to take a course
in this, you could take a
course in physical oceanography
and learn about
each of these ocean basins
in a more complete way.
But I will say that
they--there are certain parallels.
You've got a North Pacific
Gyre, just like you had a
North Atlantic Gyre.
A South Pacific Gyre, just as
you had a South Atlanta Gyre.
Here, the current is the Peru
Current, sometimes called the
Humboldt Current.
And then the South Equatorial
Current, the East Australian
Current, and then
it returns here.
The one surprise, perhaps,
is this Alaska Current.
So you get the current coming
across here from the Kuroshio
that then splits.
Some of it comes down the
California coast, and some of
it returns in the other
direction, back across the
northern stretches of the
Pacific, and returns into the
Kuroshio that way.
The South--the Southern Ocean
has its own current system,
that's the Antarctic Circumpolar
Current, sometimes
called the west wind drift.
It pretty much goes all the
way around Antarctica.
And in the Arctic Ocean, you've
got a well-defined
gyre, called the
Beaufort Gyre.
And then, as part of that, or
consistent with that, is a
current that runs kind of across
the basin, from one
side to the other, called
the Transpolar Drift.
Now, there is water leaking
in and leaking out
of the Arctic Ocean.
I've already mentioned that the
Gulf Stream extension will
come up here.
And water then will enter the
ocean--the Arctic Ocean, stay
there for several years,
presumably.
And then some of it will leak
out on the East Greenland
Current and come out that way.
There's also some exchange
between Alaska
and the Soviet Union.
There's some exchange of
water there as well.
Between the Pacific Ocean
and the Arctic Ocean.
One the interesting stories
about this Transpolar Drift is
the trick that Fridtjof
Nansen tried.
Now, you already know that name,
because he invented the
Nansen bottle.
But this was really
his claim to fame.
He wanted to be the first one
to reach the North Pole.
And he figured, why should
he have to work at it?
Why shouldn't he let nature
do the work for him?
He already had some
evidence that
Transpolar Current existed.
So he said, if I can just get
my ship locked into the ice
about here, it should carry me
close to the Arctic, to the
North Pole.
And he did that.
He left the ship here and tried
to do the rest of it by
land not by land, but
over the ice.
Couldn't make it, and ended up
having to travel on the ice
all the way back to here, where
he finally got back to
civilization.
While the ship continued
to move like this.
So it was a good idea, but it
didn't quite get him close
enough to allow him to reach
the North Pole in that way.
But it's a great
adventure book.
If you want to read about one of
the great adventure stories
in human history, read about
Nansen's attempt to get to the
North Pole using that
Tranpolar Drift.
Questions here?
OK.
Switching gears slightly,
we're interested in the
relationship between physical
oceanography, that we've been
talking about so far, and
biological oceanography.
In particular, what is it that
controls productivity in the
world ocean?
By this I mean biological
productivity.
Now the way a biologist
approaches this, is first
understand the food chain.
What feeds on what?
And I'll show you that
in just a minute.
But the most basic level, where
the food chain begins,
is called primary
productivity.
And it's usually referring to
plant life in the ocean.
Plant life requires sunlight
and nutrients.
You need to get those two things
together in order to
get the primary productivity.
And then the rest of the food
chain builds on that.
And as I'll be showing you,
there are vast parts of the
ocean that are devoid of any
primary productivity.
And for that reason, largely
devoid of any biological
activity at all.
But there are other regions in
which biological activity is
very, very active.
And if I had to categorize them,
and I'm going to try to
categorize them, I would put
them into those four
categories.
There's a lot of primary
productivity in high
latitudes, in regions of coastal
upwelling, in regions
of equatorial upwelling, and in
regions of river outflow.
And for the most part, the
rest of the ocean is very
limited, if not completely
devoid of primary
productivity.
So in the next few minutes,
we're going to talk about this
kind of way of understanding
productivity in the oceans.
So here's the typical
food chain.
You start with single-celled
life that are plants.
And they require sunlight and
nutrients, especially
phosphorus and nitrogen.
It's a carbon-based life,
which there's
plenty of carbon available.
So it usually depends on the
phosphorus and the nitrogen
that allows that
to get started.
These organisms get eaten by
small animals, so-called
zooplankton.
These are so-called
phytoplankton.
They get eaten by zooplankton.
And then, in turn, eaten by
small fish, larger fish,
larger fish, and so on.
So that's the base of
the food chain.
That's the primary productivity
there.
Now, here's the great catch
22 for ocean productivity.
You need light from the sun.
But light is absorbed rather
quickly as you go
down into the ocean.
The region that has lots of
light in the ocean, the upper
50 or 100 meters is referred
to as the euphotic zone.
E-U-P-H-O-T-I-C. The
euphotic zone.
There's a layer beneath
that that gets a
little bit of light.
And then, however, most, the
vast majority of the ocean
depth is dark.
Because the sunlight doesn't
penetrate that far.
That's the aphotic zone.
Aphotic meaning no light.
On the other hand, if you look
at the concentration of
nutrients in the ocean and
here, it's plotted versus
depth in kilometers.
Sea surface, one kilometer,
two kilometers.
Most of the nutrients,
phosphorus and nitrogen, are
in the lower parts
of the ocean.
And in the upper parts of the
ocean, where you have the
light, you have depleted
nutrients.
So here's that catch 22.
Where you've got light, you
don't have the nutrients.
Where you've got nutrients,
you don't have the light.
That's the great brake upon
ocean productivity.
To get ocean productivity,
you've got to violate this
general anti-correlation, and
get the two together.
You can't get the sunlight
deeper, so the only way to do
that is to get some of these
nutrients up to the surface.
And that'll be the focus of
our discussion for primary
productivity.
How can we get some of these
nutrients up to the surface?
Now, why is it like this?
Well, it's because you've had
some blooms of phytoplankton.
They've depleted
the nutrients.
And then their bodies will fall
gravitationally into the
lower ocean, and then rot.
And the nutrients are released
again, but because of gravity,
they're released in the lower
parts of the ocean.
And once that has happened, then
you have that depletion.
And the, at least in this
simple set of plots, the
productivity would shut down.
You need to do something to
reestablish concentrations of
nutrients in the surface waters
of the ocean in order
to get the primary productivity
reestablished.
This is one of my favorite
diagrams. It comes from a
satellite in orbit called
SeaWiFS, which looks down at
the surface of the ocean.
And by using two channels, two
reflected channels, it maps
out the concentration of
chlorophyll chlorophyll a in
this case in the surface
waters of the ocean.
So in a way, it's detecting
those phytoplankton directly,
because they have chlorophyll
in their bodies.
And so, here we have a global
map of the primary
productivity in the ocean.
It's a remarkable thing.
And the scale here, it's a
log scale, the units are
milligrams of chlorophyll per
cubic meter of ocean water.
Going from 60 units on down
to 0.01 on a log scale.
So the purple areas are
biological deserts.
There's really very little
primary productivity going on
in these areas.
We can imagine why that is,
because remember, that warm
water lens extends from
there to there.
And so, you've got this layer of
warm water floating on the
sea, very strong thermocline
beneath it, which, just like
an inversion in the atmosphere,
makes it very
difficult to mix water
vertically.
So while you probably have a
lot of nutrients just a few
hundred meters down, because
of that static stability in
the thermocline, you can't
mix it to the surface.
So let's talk about the
high latitudes.
I'll go through and check off
the four items I had there.
High latitudes are generally
high productivity.
Well, that's because that warm
water lens doesn't extend to
high latitudes.
You've got cold water
at the surface.
at depth.
You don't have a strong
thermocline in the high latitudes.
You do have, also, strong storms
in the atmosphere,
putting winds on the surface
of the ocean,
tending to mix things.
So it's pretty easy to get water
to mix up and down when
you're in the high latitudes.
And that's why a lot of the
major world fisheries are
found in high latitudes, because
you can get primary
productivity, because you can
mix up the nutrient-rich
waters into the euphotic
zone and get those
phytoplankton growing.
A second example would be let's
see, go back to the
order that I had them here.
Coastal upwelling.
There's a lot of upwelling,
a lot of productivity, for
example, along the Peru coast.
And that, we believe, is due
to coastal upwelling.
Basically, you have winds
putting a wind
stress on the ocean.
And the Ekman drift that
responds from that is pushing
water offshore.
So if you're pushing surface
waters away from the shore,
then that must be replaced
by waters
coming up from the deep.
So any time you're for example,
if the wind was like
this, the Ekman drift would be
perpendicular to that, pushing
water offshore and allowing
nutrient-rich deep waters to
come up to the surface, giving
you high productivity along
that coastline.
And you find at other
places as well.
Coastlines tend to be highly
productive because of the
upwelling and the mixing
that can occur there.
Equatorial upwelling.
I think this is the most
remarkable aspect of this
diagram, is this little line.
And some other productive
areas around it, but
especially that little
line right at the
geographical equator.
That's not at the ITCZ.
That's not approximately
at the equator.
That is at zero degrees
latitude.
There's a highly productive
region right at
zero degrees latitude.
And why would that be?
Why would there be a highly
productive region right at
zero degrees latitude?
Yeah.
STUDENT: A lot of sunlight?
PROFESSOR: A lot of sunlight.
But you know, the sun remember,
because of the tilt
of the earth, there are seasons
of the year when you
get more sunlight
here than there.
And more sunlight here
than there, in
Southern Hemisphere summer.
And really, that begs
the question
of why it's so narrow.
Really, why is it right
at the, right at the
geographical equator?
What happens, what's
special about the
geographical equator?
STUDENT: There's no
Coriolis Force?
PROFESSOR: No Coriolis force.
And along with that, it's
where the Coriolis force
switches sign, from being to
the right, to the left.
That's what's unique
about the equator.
And I think I have a
diagram for that.
In fact, I have two diagrams.
So, for coastal upwelling, if
that's the continent and the
wind is like this, it pushes
the Ekman drift offshore, it
must be replaced by upwelling.
Here's the diagram for the
equatorial upwelling.
Let's say the ITCZ is
located somewhere
north of the equator.
So the winds crossing the
equator are the southeast
trade winds.
The southeast trade winds.
So the wind stress is along
the blue arrow.
When you're in the Southern
Hemisphere, the Ekman drift is
to the left of the
wind stress.
When you're in the Northern
Hemisphere, the Ekman drift is
to the right of the
wind stress.
So now, draw a section
like this.
That is pulling water
northwards
away from the equator.
This is pulling water
southwards
away from the equator.
That water must then be
replaced by upwelling.
So imagine you're in a bathtub,
you put your hands
like this, you push
water away.
Well, that water's going to
be replaced from beneath.
And that's what's happening
right along the equator to
give equatorial upwelling.
Any questions on that
general point?
Did I cover them all,
by the way?
Let's see here.
River outflow.
Well, if you look at, for
example, where the Amazon
River comes in, where the
Mississippi comes in, where
some of the other major
rivers come in, you
see little red regions.
That's because nutrients are
brought in from the land.
The rain has fallen on the land,
moved through the soil,
picked up nutrients.
And then, where that passes
out into the ocean, you've
brought nutrients into the
euphotic zone in that way.
So that pretty much covers it.
Why you have high productivity
regions in some areas, and low
productivity regions
in other areas.
Any questions on this?
This, of course, controls where
are the major fisheries.
Now, it's a little sad to notice
that we pretty much
exploited the world's
ocean productivity.
In the blue is the total marine
fish catch from 1950,
in units of millions
of metric tons.
And it's been increasing
from the 1950s.
But then, about 1990 onwards,
it's pretty much plateaued.
In other words, we're taking
about as much edible biomass
out of the oceans as the
oceans can produce.
So the human population has
grown to the state that it's
pretty much fully utilizing
everything that the ocean is
producing in these high
productivity zones.
I wanted to just link this
curious pattern of
productivity to one famous book,
and that's Moby Dick.
You probably have
all read that.
And Captain Ahab was hunting
for a sperm whale.
Sperm whales are found in
all oceans of the world.
But occasionally, the males
will go down and join the
females on the breeding grounds
close to the equator.
And when you read that book, you
may have wondered, what's
special about the equator?
Well, now you know.
It's this equatorial upwelling
that gives rise to a high
productivity region right on
the geographical equator.
And then if you read a quote
from the book, "You meet them
on the line." Right?
By "on the line," Herman
Melville was
referring to the equator.
"Just having returned, perhaps,
from spending the
summer in the northern seas,
cheating summer of all its
unpleasant weariness
and warmth.
By the time the have lounged
up and down the
promenade..." OK.
I won't go through this in
detail, but the point is, that
it was known by the whalers
also that you had highly
productive regions in
the high latitudes.
But also, an additional high
productive region right along
the equator.
They didn't know it was because
of a shift in the
Ekman layer, but we know that
now, that you have a zone
there of high productivity.
Questions on that?
OK.
Well, we finished up the basic
section on oceanography.
Next, on Wednesday, I'm going
to be talking about El Nino,
which you can read about
in the book.
And we'll talk about this
particular interaction between
the atmosphere and the ocean.